Aujourd'hui y'a des séries pour tous les goûts !
Des courtes, des longues, des comiques, des dramatiques, historiques, documentaires, de l'animation
C'est quand même rare les gens qui te disent :
"Non moi je regarde aucune série...
-Au... Aucune, zéro !?
- Non zéro. Rien.
- Tu viens d'où ?
- Je viens de Pluton. Euh... de banlieue parisienne !
- Oh putain il m'a eu !
- Je savais !
- Maintenant je dois rentrer chez moi ! Bel esprit, bravo !"
En gros t'as 2 manières de regarder des séries : soit tu regardes un épisode de temps en temps, tu fais durer le plaisir,
soit t'as des gros problèmes d'addiction.
"Oh mais elle est géniale cette série !
- Vous parlez de quoi ?
- Là on parle de Breaking Bad la série tu connais ?
- Ah ouais paraît c'est pas mal !
- Quoi t'as pas vu ?
- Non...
- Nan mais attends mec... il faut que tu regardes, tu vas tellement kiffer c'est génial !
- J'vais regarder le premier épisode ce soir alors, j'vous dirai !
- Bon bah alors ça va t'as pu regarder ?
- J'ai tout regardé Breaking Bad !...
- Nan mais c'est pas possible ça fait plusieurs dizaines d'heures de suite...
- Je regarde plusieurs saisons en même temps !
- Hé les gars vous avez vu la nouvelle saison de Better Call Saul qu'est sor...
- Nan nan nan nan... c'est rien, tu veux pas boire de l'eau ?
- C'est une série ?
- Nan nan, apporte-lui de l'eau peut-être...
- Y'a combien de saisons ?"
Ceux qui regardent tout d'un coup, ce sont aussi le genre de gens qui quand une nouvelle saison commence,
Ils préfèrent attendre que tous les épisodes soient sortis...
Pour pouvoir tout regarder d'un coup, comme ça. Moi je ne peux pas faire ça !
Moi je peux pas faire ça,
y'a trop de risque de spoils !
Comment font les gens ?
"Là c'est bon tu peux sortir, t'as tous les épisodes de Game of Thrones qui sont sortis...
- D'accord. Enfin...
- Attends... Y'a une nouvelle saison qu'a été annoncée ?
- Euuh... Ouais...
- FERME !!
J'VEUX PAS ÊTRE SPOILÉ !!
- C'est dans 2 ans...
- CASSE-TOI !
Commencer une nouvelle série, surtout si y'a pleins de saisons,
c'est quand même des dizaines et des dizaines d'heures devant ton écran,
c'est lourd de conséquences...
Soyez pas inconscients, hein, comme les mecs qui peuvent te sortir :
"Franchement, tu devrais commencer la série Les Sopranos... ou The Wire... ou les deux !"
Mais nan !
Tu peux pas dire ça ! C'est comme si tu disais :
"Franchement, tu devrais apprendre le mandarin... ou devenir ingénieur en aéronautique...
Ou les deux !"
Avant y'avait quelques bonnes séries, elles passaient à la télé tu savais où les trouver !
Maintenant, quand tu sais pas quoi regarder et que tu lances genre Netflix,
t'as trop de choix ! Y'en a trop !
"Ça ?
- Nan... nan pas un dessin animé...
- Ah ça c'est cool !
- Nan, Tom Cruise, là ça m'saoule...
- Bon écoute, ça fait 40 minutes là qu'on cherche un truc,
franchement on aurait pu regarder un épisode entier là...
- Bah le prochain truc vas-y on le regarde hop tu choisis au pif et c'est bon on mate ça...
-T'es sûr hein ?
- Mais oui, bien sûr...
-  *tous les deux* Nan. Nan pas ça.
- *tous les deux* Aaaaaah... Nan nan nan."
Sur Netflix, quand tu regardes l'épisode d'une série,
à la fin il te démarre automatiquement l'épisode suivant,
et au bout de quelques épisodes,
il te balance un message pour être sûr que tu t'es pas endormi et t'es obligé de valider ils te disent :
-Voix Off- "Êtes-vous toujours en train de regarder votre série?
Et là quand t'appuies sur "Continuer de regarder"...
Tu te sens un peu comme une merde.
"Qu'est ce que je fais ? Pfff...
Bon allez, encore un petit épisode...
-Voix Off- : "À mon avis il doit dormir...
Qui regarderait 8 épisodes d'affilée ?
Personne ! Les gens sortent, ils font du sport, ils vont voir des expositions, ils bossent
ils seraient pas affalés comme une merde à regarder des séries pendant des heures !"
- Eh bah si, si je continue à regarder ! Voilà !
-Voix Off- : "Oups ! Désolé, bon visionnage !"
- Faut p'têt que j'aille me coucher là...
Et que je trouve un emploi aussi..."
D'ailleurs j'pense que Netflix c'est le service le plus partagé de la planète, hein on va pas se mentir...
Tout le monde veut gratter le compte de tout le monde !
Personne ne veut payer d'abonnement !
La grande question est qui va te donner son compte !
"Et le mot de passe de mon compte Netflix est attribué à...
Mon frère !"
- Je... m'y attendais pas du tout...
Merci déjà à mes parents qui sont là dans la salle qui me regardent...
Merci de m'avoir donné une sœur !
Et merci ma sœur de payer 13,99 € !
Voilà, j'suis un peu ému je m'y attendais pas du tout...
-23 R...
- J'peux jouer à ta console ?"
J'ai vécu un truc assez bizarre avec les séries.
Y'a longtemps j'regardais les séries en version française, en VF.
Et pour regarder la suite des nouvelles saisons, j'étais obligé de les regarder en VO.
Et là ça fait très bizarre de voir les personnages que tu connais avec une autre voix...
Pourtant c'est leurs vrais voix mais ça fait bizarre c'est comme si maintenant
-Voix d'Akim- : "Je parlais avec cette voix là !
Voilà je sais pas ce que ça vous fait mais...
Voilà c'est bizarre on est d'accord."
D'ailleurs en parlant de VO quand un épisode vient tout juste de..."
J'arrête avec cette voix, ne vous inquiétez pas !
Quand un nouvelle épisode vient tout juste de sortir à l'étranger en plein milieu de la nuit chez nous,
une heure plus tard, il est déjà sous-titré en français sur les sites illégaux !
Y'a des mecs qui traduisent comme ça dans la foulée, en plein milieu de la nuit, c'est un peu nos héros du quotidien !
"Ce matin j'ai vu le dernier épisode de Walking Dead.
- Ah bah il est sorti dans la nuit !
- Ouais mais je l'ai trouvé avec les sous-titres !
- Oh ! Mortel !
- Ah ouais trop bien ouais...
- Par contre v'la les fautes d'orthographes ! Non mais le mec il confond les -é et les -er !
- Sérieusement."
- Nan mais je te jure.
- Il fait ça dans la nuit à 4h du mat', c'est normal y'a p'têt des fautes...
- Faut ouvrir un Bescherelle quoi ! Moi mais les fautes ça me sort de l'histoire !
- Enfin il fait ça de son temps libre c'est sympa de sa part de traduire la nuit...
- Attends le pseudo... TraductionDarkZork28
*Rires*
- Nan mais le mec il a 8 ans ou quoi !?
- Alors l'épisode il est cool ?
- Il est dément, j'te dis ou pas ?
- Euh nan j'préfère pas...
- Alors, les verbes du premier groupe..."
Aujourd'hui les séries elles te stressent trop à tout moment il y a un personnage que t'adores qui peut mourir !
Ils font ça tout le temps dans Games Of Thrones, dans The Walking Dead, dans Joséphine ange gardien...
Nan pas dans Joséphine.
Comment font les scénaristes pour se mettre d'accord ? Ils ont un pouvoir comme ça on va tous les tuer !?
-Voix Off- : "Tu es scénariste ?"
- Est-ce que c'est un Barathéon ?
- Et non !
-Voix Off- : "Toi aussi joue à Qui Est-ce qui reste en vie ?"
- Est- ce que c'est un bâtard ?
"- Non.
- Enfin si pardon j'me suis trompé...
- Bon bah alors je le ressuscite ?
- Bah ouais.
-Voix Off- : "Qui est-ce qui reste en vie ? Un jeu HBO !"
Sous-titres : MsNewMiss (RedWine) le héro du quotidien!
Clique juste ici pour t'abonner, allez, appuie. Tu peux le faire : You can do it!